déjà
rien que les miens ça fait déjà quatre
mais c'est vrai que les ratés dans les
mariages se passe des choses parfois un
peu surprenante chacun des petites
anecdotes entre le tonton qui est ivre
mort la cousine qui s'est tapé le frérot
qui était pas prévu
parfois la la mariée qui ripe parfois la
mariée qui est libre ouais moi j'ai vu
une mariée kia qui arrivait par exemple
ah bon ah oui ça la grippe équipés alors
elle n'est pas mortelle à leiria la
grippe est arrivée à la halle a glissé
d'un huissier à la baisse--
salle compris qu'en fait tu as fait ta
s'est étonné de son mari juste le temps
de la soirée elle a glissé sur kara à la
glisser sur quelqu'un
l'aperçoit qu'elle a glissé c'est moi
[Applaudissements]
mais vous avez été jusqu'au bout pas
alors je vais pas rentrer dans le détail
les
émissions de tout savoir et au courant
alors jusque maintenant non mais est-ce
que c'était la mariée votre ami à la
base où le marié bien susciter me le
mari et moi
écoutez sa part en dose il était là
voilà les oui vous avez cette petite
malédiction n'est pas mieux peut-être
jamais sur ses traces à vous apporter la
ligne ça ne se fait pas et lannion
durait déjà comme la ration par la
relation a commencé après le vin
d'honneur et s'est terminée à lattes et
se montrent et voilà le plus tranquille
[Applaudissements]
s'est rien passé de nom s'est rien passé
de grave
rip et larry pee wee des sévices bisous
c'était sympathique wallabies
n'avaient pas revus après alors non plus
non non non l'enjeu
elle non plus donc
on vous a demandé à besoin de
connecteurs de nous raconter une
anecdote à mieux vous benjamin
c'était pour monter les vols alors on a
des petites les petites les petits dci
alors j'ai assisté à deux mariages
simultanément ça c'est vraiment
intéressant
déjà comment c'est possible d'assister à
boire et à shenzhen et man c'est quand
ils comment fait-on c'est qui qui a fait
ça moi je dirais bernard comme ça non
non non non si avec ça bernard
gousse avait bien prévu les deux
travaillent sur l'émission ce soir mais
oui non mais alors qui quitte à les
adopter
c'est toi
l'escroc vous commencez à me connaître
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé mais en
fait j'ai assisté à deux mariages en
même temps puisque quand la mariée a dit
oui au même moment j'ai un couple d'amis
qui laisse mon pote a fait sa demande à
sa femme elle a dit oui au même moment
donc fait ça a été une double fête donc
a eu le oui le vrai oui et ya eu le oui
pour futur mariage qui arrivait après
donc on a fait une demande m et c'était
super super canon les a pris les 4
devant c'était super le public est assez
des 100 m
[Applaudissements]
deux mariages en même temps si longtemps
c'était quelque chose de très romantique
d'ailleurs les deux coupes sont toujours
ensemble tu vois ça c'est beau ça arrive
c'est beau j'ai beaucoup d'admiration
qui reste s'est mariée et quoique
attendez je vais fêter cet endroit
est bien battu des records précédents
j'ai amélioré c'est vrai que c'est un
tournant c'est ta gueule au 6ème tour
c'est la turista qui a joué les démons
paris dow jones --axa tottenham n'est
pas donc c'est là tout est acquis a joué
des témoins deux alors encore une sphère
de kaka il ya aussi avec sa wii c'était
ce n'est pas l'école qui avait une petit
chien sauvage aura bateau c'était
l'autre notre bas c'était pareil par le
haut alors qui a déféqué lors du mariage
bah ça peut pas être gilles pascal il
attend toujours son premier ça va moi
j'aimerais bien belle film quelque chose
d'élégant grèce je sais pas non mais
c'est que des films c'est le malaise et
une europe qui ne s'en est pas
c'est compliqué non c'est pas moi c'est
boumerdas
bernard madoff ou les châles et avec
vous j'ai pas compris ce que c'est la
turista qui a joué les témoins
ça touristes à l'achat alors le caquet
était moins la question il faudrait être
plus simple
[Applaudissements]
c'est le dîner
mark était malade un vraiment non
densité juste vous savez le mois dernier
à marrakech pour un mariage et sa valeur
n'est pas
saint martin où aller en martinique et
en guadeloupe après rio avaler cette
année en france on fait juste pour
passer en faire des petits bisous et
donc on était dans le désert d'agde a
fait est fait dagg a fait oui c'est dans
le désert des déserts comme ça voilà
c'est très très salma à la base on vous
avait vendu un camping super luxueux
l'ema les mariés étaient les premiers
déçus parce que j'ai vécu quatre jours
sans luxe en confort sans même de quoi
changer mon mon téléphone portable c'est
à dire des heures abbas est désert et
les gens malheureusement qui nous qui
oubliait de prendre de l'eau minérale
pour se brosser les dents eh ben ils
tombaient comme des mouches comme ça
tous les jours je vous assure ce qui
fait que le chant du mariage il ya des
gens qui se tenait quand assister à la
cérémonie et qui sont partis après en
courant le public à l'art invitera aussi
alors
c'est un peu similaire à l'histoire des
débuts est tombée est tombée amoureuse
de moi
pourquoi pas deux beaux gosses pour la
mariée elle tombe amoureuse
du père dit comme
ça c'est dégueulasse moi tout ça mais
c'est pas fait exprès alors c'est vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'avais rien bien compris le début alors
je la connaissais rien c'était là
c'était là d'un cousin en plus mon
cousin se marient fort mais je
connaissais pas on va voir cette femme
magnifique bague à non graves elle me
voit vraiment elle était très belle
évidemment elle me voit elle me dit elle
veut dire mais si j'avais su j'aurais
attendu un peu avant de choisir ton
cousin à mais quelle norme et c'est tout
un jeu non c'est une blague être aimable
si tu veux abbaoui pas du tout elle me
regarder dans la soirée ces gens
je me dis mal est folle elle a un truc
je dis à ma mère elle est folle celle là
non elle est folle toi et elle m'a
poursuivi et avant de m'avancer rouler
des pelles tout ça
[Applaudissements]
bien sympa non et je vais vous alors
excusé
[Rires]
[Musique]
non c'est vrai problème parce que
c'est pratique mais je ne voulais pas
c'est un émoi le show mais non elle me
rappelle moi je lui rends la paix les
malades non non non non mais ça me gêne
pas du tout mais on peut me toucher
partout je dis rien
libre
mais avec des mots avec des mots
est embrassée fougueusement helm
embrasser fougueusement elle a découvert
mon corps elle a découvert que dieu
m'avait gâté
bien fourre
tout cas c'est vrai et ils ont divorcé
beaucoup plus tard mais j'ai gardé une
petite relation arrêté au deuxième avec
le concert lui sam est rendu compte là
on peut arriver la mariée comme ça mais
regardez le regarder tout le temps bye
bye j'imagine dans sa chance elle aussi
très bien c'est quand même toujours les
vieux sont très gênants 13 et à la vidéo
surtout le l'europa il souvent très
mauvais rennes et dacia vaut d'être il
était marié vous êtes à la table mais
rares
alors alors le mariage de mon ami c'est
fini aux urgences
entre magali bertin non c'est toi pas il
faut enchaîner il faut un chat noir
alors s'il respecte moi c'est pas moi
j'irai nicolas rentrer
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les été attaqué par un american staff
les bonnes à plusieurs vous à l'erreur
et bien avec à vous attaquez vous avez
compris les plus mais plus haut et qu'on
sache t1 c'est delphine tous les coups
les films mais non non non c'est moi
vacher chat noir mois et si j'allais
dans en fait je vous explique nous dans
le mariage
juif c'est vrai qu'on a tendance à lever
les gens sur une chaise oui il est sorti
on est deux qui avaient bu donc ils
l'ont enlevée et la mariée là pour
casser la croûte
et en fait elle est restée allongée donc
elle a fait son mariage allongé
souffrait de douleurs et puis je crois
que c'est vers 5 heures du matin on a
fait nos urgences c'est sympa vers 5
heures du matin
[Applaudissements]
chez sfr on porte des mariés thomson est
ainsi envoyé en l'air voila voila ca oui
moi j'ai fait ça au malsaucy ensuite
c'est génial il y en a toujours un qui a
bu un peu trop quoi et c'est très
dangereux oui c'est pas beau voyage à la
à consommer bien sûr avec modération de
marges de l'alcool n'est pas des
mariages il n'y a pas de limitation dans
mariage
on va avancer je me suis endormi pendant
la cérémonie de mariage ça s'arrête chez
moi
j'ai lu son vernis golf à saint louis
barye voilà un enterrement de vie de
garçon la veille et je me suis retrouvé
chez avait importe au mariage ont même
mis à une table avec un monsieur un
belge et qui apparaît comme ça et qu'il
me dit à un moment donné je suis dans ma
femme et mon fils
m'a parlé parlé parlé et aiderait
financièrement des je me suis endormi
sur la table comme ça pendant pour une
petite bière c'est ça ma prison
public est toujours ravi
on a la broutille j'ai assisté aux bobos
maria gil ou facéties saisi la brute et
à la rue
alors on m'invite jamais en mariage lors
balawi normal et là il travaillait un
début des années 90 au journal
téléphoner on était une toute petite
équipe y avait une collègue que je
connaissais à peine elle me dit je me
marie la semaine prochaine tu viens
c'était près de vernon dans l'eure à la
sortie des boucles de la seine donc déjà
j'avais pas de voiture je savais pas
comment y aller j'étais tout seul à
l'époque je trouve une voiture givet et
puis j'arrive je croyais dans le village
comme vous vous trouvez une voiture vous
pour aller quelque part
voilà ce que j'avais pas les moyens à
l'époque elwen donc voila vous empruntez
les voitures aussi marival gide avant
cassé c'est vous fait des dégâts c'était
le mot car elle vous souvenez des quatre
est la voiture la
manière comme ça le halal est donc
j'arrive comme ça je me garais tout et
je croyais que c'était là je rentre je
vois que c'est plein j'avance et je dis
mais c'est bizarre je la connaissais pas
très bien mais avec le voilà au pub le
dollar connaissaient pas et qu'on n'y
avait plus de place on dit les gens de
10 au troisième rang etc et c'était pas
du tout bon mariage connaissait pas les
gens du tour et comme j'étais là j'irai
jusqu'au bout du jeu gratuit s'est
félicité jamais allé aux bombes à
l'achat
on a fini vous fabien godelle si pardon
oui ma vie mes jambes oui on a fait tout
pour ça
si longtemps et je suis con il est et
quel
mariage a détruit une ambiance a
tendance à les les films de mariage fait
attention c'est à qui vous demandez les
témoignages et c'est à dire souvent des
catastrophes et on a franchement les
choses épouvantables sur le marié et la
mariée et ça ils pensent tard plaisir et
c'est une tana ce total arrêté de nous
faire chier pénale
je vous en je vous en conjure c'est un
piège d'abris alors vous accusez
disposait donc du coup il y avait le
film est donc les témoins ont sorti des
photos dossiers et sur une des photos le
marié faisait un peu la fête il
embrassait un peu et notamment des
photos de jeunesse sauf que au final la
salle en faisant le calcul ils se sont
rendu compte qu'à cette période là le
couple était déjà ensemble mais c'est un
peu compliqué c'est partir en sucette
bah du coup ça ses amis un peu un froid
quoi et je suis quand même et puis ta
vie ton ami la musique
la libéro